Sean Spicer is the White House press
secretary and one of the things he does
is hold press briefings at the White
House and take questions from reporters
he's sort of like a conduit to the point
of view of Donald Trump and the Trump
administration and we've seen the
disdain for the media from the Trump
administration and this was furthered
yesterday when Sean Spicer just left the
Daily Press briefing without taking any
questions press secretary goes to the
press briefing doesn't take any
questions here's video and audio from
that well you guys just email where that
wall is from exactly so we can identify
location
this is very unusual and it is yet
another way in which the ability of the
public to even know what's going on is
being hampered reporters had already
been noticing that the briefings were
getting shorter and shorter and shorter
and Spicer was taking fewer and fewer
questions and this is sort of the
conclusion to the shortening and you
heard the end there Pat someone say what
about the Putin call which was yelled
out and there's obviously speculation
that maybe Sean Spicer didn't want to
have to answer questions about the phone
call that Donald Trump had yesterday
with Vladimir Putin but I think it goes
well beyond that don't you think yeah
and I think it's especially because
Donald Trump has had a very bad week and
that's a high bar to clear but Sean
Spicer probably doesn't want to answer
questions as to whether or not Andrew
Jackson would have stopped the Civil War
why we had a civil war right as we know
Sean Spicer is not very good when he has
to talk about history and I'm sure that
he would pull that thing if asked about
it
where if he was asked about Trump's
comments about the Civil War he would
say listen the Civil War historians have
dealt with that Donald Trump's opinion
of the Civil War doesn't matter is that
will Trump's the one who said nobody has
dealt with it and that we just don't
know why we had the civil war Trump
supporters okay I'm talking to you right
now seriously let's talk honestly I know
that you can see what Sean Spicer did
yesterday and say this is a great sign
that the Trump administration is just
not going to be bullied by the press
does it really project strength for the
question answerer in chief of your
administration to leave a briefing
without taking any questions that
doesn't project any strength or
confidence to be no he's upset and he's
taking his ball and going home you know
it's funny how Sean Spicer is a
household name and you think of any
other White House press secretaries in
the past who were household names I mean
no one really know who Jay Carney and
Josh earnest were well but Robert Gibbs
was very popular a lot of the ladies
found him very very attractive from what
I read on the internet and some men too
of course but that is not really because
he was making a fool out of himself I
looked online to see what trumpets were
saying about this a lot of them were
loving loving it saying stuff like
Spicer really showed those liberal media
loons Spicer actively avoided doing his
job with no explanation whatsoever and
now that's something to cheer and again
this is closing down the lines of
communication between press and
administration by extension you're
putting distance between the public and
the administration this is an
authoritarian tendency of the
administration you want to speak to the
audience through one-way communication
rallies where dissent won't be tolerated
commercials like the one we showed you
yesterday where Donald Trump is just
touting the non-existent accomplishments
of his first hundred days you don't want
any two-way communication where anybody
actually gets to ask John Spicer
questions and many trumpets want an
authoritarian style they want this
regime type where Trump gets what he
wants you get rid of the checks and
balances you get rid of expectations
that there's going to be any two-way
communication with the public or the
press period
Trump quit an interview this week we
played the clip earlier when he was
asked to defend the bogus claims he made
about Obama wiretapped knee and now this
they say Pat that they're the ones
against trigger warnings and safe spaces
they're constantly retreating to their
safe spaces when there's any expectation
of having to defend what it is that they
say right and I also wonder if Sean
Spicer is running away here because he's
legitimately bad at his job or that his
job is so difficult in defending the
Donald Trump White House that no one
could do it effective I think
both I think it's a combination of the
two he's being asked to defend the
indefensible and he's doing it in a way
that is drawing extra attention to
himself and with a lot of these gas from
Spicer it's going to be kind of bad no
matter what because you're defending
terrible things but he's doing it in a
particularly bombastic and outrageous
way and you know he it's his political
career that he's destroying today's
episode of the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS